半時瞑想 アッパナー・バワーナっていうのは瞬間だけ
パリカンマ・バワーナにはすごい時間がかかる
これ何年かかるかわからない
焼き付いたらまたどれぐらい時間かかるかわからない
でもサマーディは瞬間に生まれるんです
瞬間に生まれて瞬間に消えちゃうんです
ですからバワーナはつありますけど
1番目と 2番目にはすごく時間がかかる
3番目っていうのは瞬間の出来事なんですね
で まあ大体それぐらいで終わりますけど
それからこの仏教で注意しているところがありまして
で この例えば青い色の円盤を見て瞑想するとする
その瞑想する間は この青い色はいろいろ変化を起こしちゃうんですね
光って見えたり 大きくなって見えたり
小さくなって見えたり
いろいろ波を打ったりしたり
それからこの青い光の中からなんか海に
海というか ウジ虫みたいないろいろあっちこっち動いたりとかね
あるいはちらちらっとなんかあっちこっちなんかホタルみたいに光見えたりとかね
いろいろ変化が起きちゃうんですね
いろんな変化が起きても
目を閉じたら焼き付いてないとまだまあファーストステージなんですね
この青い円盤の中からどんどん光が見えてきたんだけど
じゃあOKやってことじゃないんです
じゃあ目を閉じたらどうですかと
目を閉じたら頭に焼き付いてないんだったら
あんたまだまだパリカンマステージだよ
で すっごく喜びを感じます
どんどんどんどん青いだけ見えるようになる
円盤の縁が見えなくなっちゃうんです
ただ青いのみと それだけ感じちゃうと
すごくいくらか楽しくはなってきます
一応脳細胞はいっぱいエンドルフィンは作るんですけどね
いっぱいというか それなりに
だから喜びを感じますけど
でも 第2ステージで行ったかないかということは
やっぱり目を閉じてみなきゃわからないんですね
自分がコピーしたんですかと
で コピーしたならば もう壁見てもそちら青く見えちゃう
電気消して目を閉じても
この円盤ちゃんと見えてくる
その円盤はぴったし見た円盤とぴったしというわけじゃないんです
それはその人の能力次第のものなんですね
例えばコピー機械でコピーしたようなカラーコピーしたような感じで
まるっきり大きさも同じということではないんです
それなりには変わり変わっちゃうんですね
だから本人の脳細胞に焼き付いたものだから
その本人に受け取りやすい
理解しやすい大きさと色で
それは記録されるんです
これは瞑想だから このそれなりにちゃんとした仕来りやってるんだから
変にはなりませんだからね
その人に集中しやすい大きさで色で
色も変わるんです 自分が作ったものの色とコピーした時の色は違うんです
頭でコピーした時の色は違うんです
ですからこの同じ色なんですけど
色は違う で そこで瞑想すると
それからこの自分を吸い込まれるというか
一体になったという時は対象また変えなくちゃいけないんです
いきなり対象が化け物になってしまって
自分を吸い込んでしまっちゃうと
あるいは自分が消えてしまって
対象のみ瞬間存在したんだと
これ瞬間のことで その時の対象はまた違う
まあそれはどういうどういう形かと
テキストでは明確に説明してますけど
大体テキストの方が光として説明
全部説明してるんですね
まあそこで仏教で注意しているのは
そういうものはすべて幻覚だよということ
で そこをその一言が仏教にだけあるんです
幻覚や そこは梵我一如だと
魂の発見だと ジャイナ教のアージワカ教では魂には色があるんだと
そのその人には青い魂
赤い魂 白い魂と色々あるんだと
そこまで行ったりする
そこで吸い込まれちゃったら
まあ梵我一如だと言ったりする人々もいる
あるいはこれこそ仏性だと
如来の世界だとと言ってる人もいる
これは成仏だと勘違いする人もいる
これこそ実体だと この世の中は幻覚だという人もいる
だからこの瞑想はみんなやってますけど
サマーディ瞑想は それなりに哲学が違っているのはそういうわけなんですね
本物だと思ってるんです
仏教はそこでたとえ高いサマーディ作ったっても
見たものは経験したものは幻覚だと
じゃあ幻覚だったらなんでやらせているんですかというと
その幻覚がありがたいわけじゃなくて
心で作った統一したあのエネルギーが必要だよと
それであなたは幸福じゃないか
すごいパワーを持ってるんだから
心に統一したパワーっていうのは
統一するってことはすごいことでしょ
空手やってる人々でも
あの もったいないことやってるでしょ
あの瓦割ったりとか 鉄を曲がったりとかね
喉で で でもあれにはものすごい集中力が必要なんです
統一することは必要 でないとできません
だから鉄棒曲がってどうなるかというと
ただもったいないことをやっただけで
瓦を割って無駄なことをやっただけで
それは何の意味もないんです
スプーン曲げても何の意味もないんで
それだったらこの鉄筋コンクリートを作るところとか
どこかとか そこで適当なところでささささささっと曲がってくればね
機械より早く曲がってくれるんだったら
それで金にもなりますけどね
だからそういうくだらんことは
仏教ではね まあパフォーマンス的なものはもうやってはいけませんと
意味がないんだと ということで
でも意味がないんだけど
あなたに集中力があるということは大変な素晴らしい結果だよと
それはまああなたには役に立ちますと
一つはもう頭から体中からいつでも喜びが生まれてくる
それで苦しみが消えちゃうでしょ
例えば脳細胞がいっぱいβエンドルフィンなんか作ったりすると
あまり食べなくても物事を済むし
もうそんなもうそっちゅう病気になるということもなくなっちゃうし
あれ欲しいこれ欲しいっていうこともなくなっちゃうし
何のことなく喜びを感じながら生きていられるし
それでかなりの苦しみが消えてしまうんですね
食べる量っていうのはものすごく極力少なくなる可能性はありますね
壊れる細胞に必要なものだけ食べてるぐらいになって
で 他のものは心の精神的なエネルギーで自分を支えられますし
で そういうことが それから何か新しいものを知りたくなったら
集中力をすでに持っているんだから
すぐ知ることもできるし
仏教が考えているのは
この智慧にはすごいエネルギー必要なんですね
前の説明でも言ったでしょうけど
単なる性格分析するということにしたっても
仏教が必要としている智慧の大きさっていうのはもう並のものじゃないんで
この軽々く一人前の仏教徒にはならないんです
信仰者にはなりますけどね
信じますよと 本物の仏教徒になるということは
もう本物の仏教ということは
もう偉大なる人物なんです
もうとっくに もうもう指導者であって
人間のもうなんて言いますか
リーダー格なんですね
それをお釈迦様はいつでもその人は先輩であって
みんなに道を案内する人であって
そういう人には他の人々は従うしか道がないんだと
なぜならば 彼が道や道を知っているんだと
人が頼るんだったら その人に頼ってみなさいと
その人はもう間違いを直してくれるんだというふうな
このすごい人格なんですね
ですから 夜叉尼ぐらいでも悟らなきゃ
まあお釈迦様は信仰確立という言葉さえ使ってないんだからね
夜叉尼悟ったらまあ信仰確立しましたと
で そこまでもう修行っていうのは
我々の知識 智慧 包容力
忍耐 そういうものはどんどんどんどん強くして強くて丸めた立派な人間を作っていく過程なんですね
ですから この悟りの方に持ってきたければ
厳密にものを見られる
電子顕微鏡でぐらいのもうもう鋭くものを見られるという能力が必要なんですね
本当の客観性と本当にデジタルで物事を見たり判断したりする能力が必要でしょう
だからサマーディの能力はもうありがたいとということで推薦しているだけなんです
何見たかというのは放っておいたあの単なる幻覚だから
観音様を見ようか 阿弥陀様を見ようか
お釈迦様は見ようか それ以外はもういい加減にしなさい
幻覚と でも幻覚といっても長い
何年も時間かけて修行を積んだところの結果なんです
だからそのこのデジタル的な説明はいつでも仏教で進んじゃうんですね
だから体験した一体になったそのものは幻覚なんですけど
それによって自分が持った能力は役に立ちますと
だからサマーディという統一した力が
だから浄力と書いてますからね
サマーディバラと 浄力は戻ったと
浄だった経験は捨てたと
そういうことで 仏教の世界ではたとえサマーディ作っても神秘主義ではありません
他の世界では瞑想しちゃうと当然神秘体験なんですね
それは 例えばハレーラーマーハレークリシュナとかね
これは人ぐらい踊りながら唱えちゃうと
もうポーンとなって頭がなんか変になっちゃって
なんかもう宇宙と一緒になったという経験が生まれてくるんだとよく書いてるんですね
そこで彼らが神秘主義者なんですね
それは事実やと それこそ真理だと
あなた方は幻覚の世界にいるんだと言うんだから
ちゃんとした神秘主義
正真正銘の 同じ経験 仏教で瞑想していたところで神秘主義ではないんですね
なんかあまりにも都合のいい話ですけど
仏教でも認めない これを自分が
例えば他の宗教の人と仏教の人が二人で仲良く
お互いに修行者だからね
仲良くやりましょうと言って
同じ瞑想をやったとする
仏教の人には違う瞑想をやったって一向に構いませんだから
同じ瞑想をやったところで
二人とも同じ経験を得たんだとする
それで我々は仏教の人は神秘主義者ではなくて
あなたは神秘主義やと言うんですね
その人は怒るかもしれません
なんでそんなこと言うんです？二人で同じ瞑想やって同じ経験を得ているんではないかと
と文句言うかもしれませんだけど
これはしょうがないんです
仏教はデジタルだから
これ経験は幻覚ですよと
幻覚っていうのは瞑想がなくてもあるでしょうと
夢の一つでしょうに 夢見る時は夢自体は実体でしょうし
でも目が覚めたら何のことない嘘なんですね
そこでじゃあ我々現に生きている今の幻想の世界はどうですか？と
まあそれも幻覚ですよとは言うんだけど
神秘主義にはならないんですね
あ これは綺麗な花ですよと言ったことは現象であって
実際のものではないんです
だからといって神秘主義ではないんですね
なぜでしょうかと 例えば仏教のある一派であるこの唯識学派ありますね
彼らが言うのは 外の世界は存在しない
外の世界というのは 心が投影した
映した心の同じ波動だと
だから自分が自分の心に
心そのものが外へ映してもらって
また同じ心を刺激しているんだと
という話があって ですから客観的な世界は存在しないと
というと神秘主義なんです
そこでテーラワーダ仏教でいうのは
まあバラの花を見てもご飯見ても
牛を見ても目という機械は決まってるんだから
その目という機械が何に反応するかと
反応するものは決まってるんだと
だから同じものに反応するんですね
なぜならば 目は音には絶対反応しないんだから
光にだけ反応する でもどんな光にも反応するわけじゃなくて
ある条件の中で光には反応する
例えば光そのものを目に入ったら
見えたということにはならないんですね
光は反射してくると反射したところ
反射したその場所で見えたという錯覚が生まれる
太陽を直接見るとかなりひどい目に遭うだけであって
太陽の光 他のものに当たってくると
ああ綺麗な世界だという風に幻覚が生まれる
そういう風に言うんであって
だから否定しても肯定してもないんです
だから因果法則に則って働きは説明していく
ですから 瞑想 サマーディの世界で
なんかすごい不可思議なものを体験しちゃうんですね
見たりはしますけど それもあくまでも幻覚であるという
だからサマーディっていうのは我々この妄想する働きの延長線なんです
あり得もしないものを妄想したりするでしょうに
そこでやがてそれは本物になってしまっちゃうんですね
例えばある人を憎もうとする
嫌な人やと 別に何もことしなかったかもしれませんだけど
ただほんのちょっとのことで自分が嫌という反応を出しただけなんです
それで その嫌という反応はどんどん心の中で妄想の過程で回転させちゃう
回転させると どんどんその感情が強くなって強化するんですね
強化してくると 自分にはその人を見えなくなっちゃうんです
見えるのは全くの嫌な人なんです
それで自分は 嫌な人に対して攻防狂暴になって何か行動を起こしちゃう
その人を批判したり 殴ったり
貶したりする それで第三者から見たっていうのは
この二人は良くないんだと
関係は良くないんだと
本人から見たら自分が怪我しているんだからね
人を殴ろうとしたところで殴り返されて怪我しているんだから
やっぱり結局それはそうやって現実化になってしまっちゃうんです
だから精神的な病気な人の場合も同じ心の働きなんですね
例えば世の中はすごい細菌だらけだと
細菌だ 細菌だと思ったりする
まあ細菌だらけっていうことは別にそれだけのことなんですけど
そこでちょっと細菌が嫌だという気持ちが生まれたところで
その感覚だけ心の中で妄想として働き出しちゃって
本人にとっては誰でも全部細菌だらけになってしまった
それでもう手袋をはめたまんまで人が部屋に来るのは嫌ですよと
ああだこうだとか もうありったけの空気清浄機やらね
いろんなものをつけたりして
何者も触らないとかね
というふうに精神的な病気になる
あの最近亡くなった大山さんっていうんですかね
すごいあのおばあちゃんで
この女の子の服を着ていた人
大山さん あ？大谷 あ？ 大山
大山雅人 え？昌子 その大屋雅子さんがものすごいもう金持ちで億万長者でしたけど
だからこのあるテレビ局からこの女の子のアナウンサーがいて
もうまあまあ どうせくだらん番組だけど
彼女の部屋とかうちとか紹介すると
これはもう全部豪華で豪華で豪華で
ものすごい気持ち悪くて
ピンク色ばっかしでということでね
何使おうと使おうか ものすごい究極的なものしか使わないということで
で そこであの部屋に行って
あまり部屋に来るのはあまり嫌がっちゃう
ベッドルームとか嫌がっちゃうんだけど
とにかく行ったと そこであの
まあだからテレビ番組だからできるだけふざけて出すことするでしょうね
だからふざけてちょっと遊んでとかね
まあそういう面白くしようとね
努力いっぱいありますから
そういうアナウンサーたちであろうか
このレポートをやっている人々も
わざとバカなことをやったり
わざとふざけたりっていうのは一生懸命なんですね
仕事を だからそれで食べてるんだから
そこでベッドに座ろうとしったら
すごくもうダメダメダメと怒られるんですね
座ったってもベッドは爆発するわけでもないし
それよりはもうそのまま座ってベッドをむちゃくちゃにするところでいろいろ怒られたりとか
いろいろ反応過剰反応したりしたところで番組に番組として成り立ちますけどね
で それで一応これやめたんだけど
そこでこのなんか世界でどこにもないなんとか口紅ですか
これはなんとかなんとかのところで
もうどんなメーカーやらああだこうだ言って
こういう口紅ですよと
それでそうですかと 彼女はそれ開けて
こうやって口にちょっとつけたんです
つけたらこの女がすっごく怒ったんです
あれほど金持ちだから
それ口紅ぐらいじゃああんた持っていけと言ったっても
何のことないでしょう
にものすごく怒るんですね
あんた直接口紅つけたでしょうと
言って またティッシュを持って
あれもう口紅をね まあ拭いて拭いて拭いて
もうかなりの量 まあ 1ヶ月間ぐらいの量を拭いて消しておいたんですね
そこで本人は直接口紅につけないんだ
これはブラシなんていうます
そこでもってこうこうやるんだと
それでも同じことですか
あのバカもんがね 死んだんだから言ったって意味がないんですけどね
だからそういうのは精神的には病気ということなんですね
皆様知ってる人の例で言ったんだけどね
でも病気なんですね ですから
このそうやって精神的なね
病気な人々いっぱいいますけど
とにかくこの働きは同じ過程なんですね
何かイメージが心に焼き付いちゃって
それは勝手に繁殖するというか
勝手に妄想を通して回転させる
何でもいい 何か頭に入っちゃったらそれを繁殖することができます
で どんどんそれのイメージが自分に湧いてきて
見えてきて これはまあ例えば観音様の仏像を見たところですごい気に入っちゃってしまって
頭に焼き付いてしまったところで
そればっかり考えているところで夢でも見えるとかね
それはいいんです なぜかというと
これ宗教の世界だから
本人が喜んで終わっちゃうんですね
私には特別に観音様が見えてるくるんだと
だから守られてるんだということで元気になるんですね
それはそれで結構なんですけど
でもやっぱりバイキンだと
世界は細菌だらけだと思ったら
元気になることじゃなくて
精神的に病気になってしまっちゃうんです
もう人と喋れなくなっちゃうし
近寄れなくなっちゃうし
でも仏教のデジタル的な思想から見れば
2つとも同じ働きなんです
心の それで一つ選んで
まあ観音様があなたの夢の中で見えるんだったら
それはそれでいいとせんとクサラですよと
逆のことを思っちゃったら
これアクサラです 不戦ですよ
というだけ それを結果から見るんですね
あなた苦しむか幸せになるかということで
だからある幻覚から幸せが生まれるし
ある幻覚から苦しみが生まれるし
でも幻覚には変わりはないんだと
そういうふうに理解してほしいんですね
だから瞑想中見えるものを体験するものっていうのは
そういうことで この全て捨てなくちゃいけない
執着してはいけない 単なる幻覚
だから幻覚を見てそれで喜ぶんだったら
自分も同じ道を歩んでるんだと
この精神的にイカれて病気になってる人と同じ道を歩んでるんだっていうことは理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
ただ 違うところは 自分の幻覚の方では自分が楽しいんだと
楽だと それだけのこと
ポジティブ的になっただけのことで
だからポジティブ的になる部分はやっぱり評価しなくちゃいけないんです
例えば そうやって観音様が見えたり
阿弥陀様見えたり イエス様見えたりしちゃうと
本人がものすごく喜んで喜んで守られているんだとか
大丈夫やと自分が 言って元気になって勇気が出てくる
ですから そこら辺は評価しなくちゃいけない
逆の幻覚生まれちゃったら勇気のどころか生きていられなくなっちゃいますから
そこで世の中の間違っているところは
世の中は全て細菌やと思ってる人がおかしいんだと言いながら
おかしいんじゃないんです
その人言ってることは正しいんです
おかしい あなた治療しなくちゃいけないんだと
治療を受けなさいと言って
イエスが見えるという人が精神病気だと扱わないんです
だからおかしいと それもおかしいんです
私は神様だと言った人が病気ですよと言わないんですね
私がはっきりと言うと
私は失礼な人だと 他人を侮辱しているんだと
私にもまた跳ね返ってきますけど
私は言ってるのは本当のことなんです
私は神様だと言ってる人はもう同じ病気なの
治りませんね あんな調子だと
そこでサマーディという場合も心一つしかないんだから
法則はそれほどたくさんないんだから
世の中で 法則はすごい単純だから
だからお釈迦様と同じ単純法則で
それまた間違わないようにと
ちょっと編集しているんですね
だからブッダの以前もサマーディの世界が当然ありましたし
お釈迦様はそれを教えてもらったし
でもそれ直したんですね
科学的にきちんと科学的に
直して見たものは幻覚であって
得た収穫は創出性やと
すごいパワーがエネルギーがもらったと言って
わずかでも精神的な病気にならないようにそこを気をつけておくんです
そういうわけで いつでも瞑想っていうのは大変気をつけて指導を受けてやりなさいっていうのはそういうわけなんです
ちゃんとした知ってる人から指導を受けないと
これは精神的に病気になる同じ道を歩んでいることなんです
実際にもそういう例っていうのはいくらでもあります
瞑想しておかしくなったという
いくらでもあります これは刀の上に歩くことと同じなんです
ちゃんと歩かないとっていうことで
そこで瞑想の進む状態はこの前はすごく説明しましたから
第1禅定作ったところで
この五つの方法で訓練するんですね
で これはこのパンチャワシーと言うんですから
パンチャワシー 五持戒
そこら辺は遠い昔に説明しました
で 五持戒も仏教だけかもしれません
ヨーガ・スートラにあるかどうか分かりません
この五持戒の訓練方法
サマーディ得たところで喜んで終わるんじゃなくて
何回何回も同じ経験に入っては出てくる
入っては出てくる 入っては出てくるということで訓練するんですね
それでそれは絶対的やという気持ちがなくなっちゃうんですね
なくなるだけじゃなくて
自分の統一的な力がものすごくぎっしりと自分の身につくんですね
入っては立ち上がる 入っては立ち上がる
それで入って あれは始まる瞬間だけですから
どんどん入って同じ経験体験したり体現したりすると
その経験の中である時間いられることもできます
そこでいられる時間伸ばしたりしたりして
時間一体感で言おうとかね
そうやって五持戒するんですね
五持戒 五つのアディッターナ・ウッターナ・アワッジナ
なんとかなんとかですね
そこはまた五持戒は何でしょうかとまた読み直してください
それで一番その中でもいい素晴らしいところは
この禅定から立ち上がって
禅定の中では何も思考も何も働かないんだから
禅定から立ち上がって普通の心に戻ってから
自分が何を体験したかと客観的に観察する
して そこで客観性を持ったので
そこでこの病気にならない
しっかりしたサマーディの成長が生まれてくるんですね
その瞬間で私にはこういう状態があったと
慈悲あってとか喜びもあったんだと
ああだこうだとか そういう風にどんな状況でしたかと
後で厳密に観察する そうするといいところも悪いところも見えてきて
心は健康に育ててはいくんです
だから健康な心っていうのはもう至難の業なんですよ
結局は みんな妄想の中で自分を作っている
妄想の中で生きている病気な人々なんです
だから悟ってない限りは病気だと
精神的な病気だという仏教の言葉というのはそういう意味なんですね
そこを五持再終わってから第二禅定にチャレンジする
それからまた五持再やって第三禅定にチャレンジすると
それから無色界の瞑想法の瞑想法を私はこのずっと説明しましたので十分で
また繰り返す必要はないんです
あの 説明していないのはこの尋数のお話なんですね
で 瞑想と尋数というあの特別なものなんですけど
うーん  あのチャットでの 2枚目で右側の方に丸と三角があるんですけど
なになに？ 丸と三角  うん
どこか違うんでしょうか
印が 2枚目の右の方 右側に
うん これはそう パリカマニミット
ウッガハニミットのところですね
先生の注釈が下に書いてあって
そこでなんか書いてあったんで一応分けてみたんですけど
取りつけないとまるで全部に丸つけてる感じになってると思うので
仮に仮って書いてあるんですけど
これ何でしょうかというと
あの第一禅定が生まれませんね
ここでパリカマニミット
ウッガハニミットあるでしょ
遍差想 受想とありますね
で 横の三角書いてるところは遍差想だけなんですね
丸書いてるところは遍差想と受想両方生まれるんですね
だからちょっと注解と言った方が良かったかもね
三角は遍差想のみと 丸は遍差想と受想と
それからもっともっと直さなくちゃいけないとこあります
この 無色の四つありますね
無色の四つの場合も三角なんですけど
そこは私もどちらに入れればいいかっていうことは
私さえもわからないんです
これ三角 これ偏差層ではないんですね
無色の瞑想だから まあとにかく十に書いてる無色四がありますね
で 無色四の場合は三角ではなくて違う印書いてください
星でも まあ三角だから四角しか書かないものはないんだけどね
まあ一応あのもう一つ三角つけて
あの何形にするんですか？え？いや
下にもう一つ三角つければ
この ダイヤ形になるでしょ
もうなんとか変化させてください
星形でもどっちでもいいんです
そこでその変化はどういう意味かというと
これおそらく私のあの私見ですけど
私見ですけど あの守正と二層
あるいは守正のみでもいいんです
じゃあ守正のみにしましょう
そうするとはっきりします
星形書いて説明に守正のみと
それからその四つにこの最後の行ありますね
次層の行が 行と言うんですか
列ですね この次層の列にまた丸入れてください
それで終了です そこの問題は
で まだあのメモ書けなかったならばまた繰り返してみましょうか
この違うところが出てくるのは十に書いている無色の四つなんですね
この無色の四つの三角を好きな形にする
星形かダイヤ形かどちらかと
好きな形にして注書くんです
それは守正 と注書く そこでこの無色の次の列に最後の列にまた丸入れちゃうんですね
これは次層ですね それでその問題は解決する
上の三角にはあの 偏差層のみ
まあとにかく次にヴィパッサナーの瞑想に行かなくちゃいけないんだから
サマーディ瞑想今日とにかく終わらなくちゃいけないんです
そこであのまあ五分間で人数歴は終わります
あのとにかくこの仏教で言ってる人数歴っていうのも
あのまあかなりの まあどうせ客観的で科学的なことばっかり喋ってるんだから
あのもう二つの人数を考えてるんですね
だからそこは全部説明しちゃうとものすごい膨大な膨大ですからね
で まあまず言えるのは
このどんな人にも人数できるということはない
まあ人数っていうのは
まあ現代風に超能力としましょう
これはどんな人にもできるわけじゃないんですが
だからといって不可能ということでもないんです
それはまあ能力の問題で
まあ一応我々論理的には四歳前に音楽を始めたら
絶対音感とかなんとかとかできたりしまして
きちんとした演奏できるようになるんだと
で 十二歳飛んじゃったら
まあただご苦労だけでそれほど上手にはならないんですね
ということは まあ私たちにしたっても
まあ四歳やっとなる前でもし始めてなれば
やっぱり絶対音感も知っていて
もうかなりの大物になる可能性はあります